now our next guest who was at the heart
of the brexit negotiations until the
summer when he dramatically quit over
the Prime Minister's chuckles proposal
so what does former Bret's at Secretary
David Davis make the situation we're in
at the minute well let's find out shall
we thank you very much for being with us
on there early on the Sunday mornings
appreciated now this is presumably the
last Conservative Party conference
before we leave the European Union Boris
Johnson the former foreign secretary on
the front pages of the newspaper today
describing the current proposal on the
table as deranged what's the adjective
that you would choose to describe the
checkers plan just wrong I mean Boris
specialize in more dramatic language
than me but you're wrong I mean it
doesn't do what either what the
referendum led people to expect
bring back control of laws it absolutely
explicitly doesn't do that it doesn't
bring back control of borders so those
two things straight away and it's much
more than that but just two things by
the way it doesn't mean referendum
promised all indeed a manifesto promised
so it's not it's not something even when
it's even what it's done even was
concluded if we got checkers the
European wouldn't go away the toothache
we've had it for 30 years on this
subject would still be there from other
20
so it's not the right answer so you know
you can't help but thinking we're here
aren't we in a situation six months
before we leave the European Union
Theresa May says that the only credible
proposal on the table is checkers you
say that it's wrong you gotta take some
responsibility for that Avenue because
she would practice it secretary for two
years we should read my resignation
letter I told her at each stage where I
thought we were going the wrong way from
the way we started negotiations
immediately after the election campaign
the concession on Ireland in December I
said no that's not the way Primus the
end of day is the lead negotiator she
decides at each stage I thought well
maybe I could make that work even though
I don't get it right these but
eventually I got the point you can't
make it work today it is so far of what
is the right strategy they don't listen
to you because you've got to take
responsibility for that because you can
fail too because I failed to persuade
the Prime Minister that that's quite
right and the the simple truth however
is you got a whole system here I mean if
you added up all the permanent
secretaries who voted to leave the
European Union I suspect you come for
the answer zero you know the whole of
Whitehall has a particular perspective
and I think as I've said already they
miss they misread Europe and misread the
way a negotiation should be played they
also misread what wasn't what was an
acceptable outcome for the British
people now all of those things you know
one man couldn't stop one of the reasons
for resigning was to make it absolutely
plain that this issue was not capable of
being resolved that the way the
government was go I couldn't do that in
government I was in government in
cabinet took the view I'm not gonna
brief I'm not gonna spin I'm not gonna
talk against my colleagues you could
only do that outside the cabin
so who is to blame them if it Teresa may
is it is that the officials around her
it's Ollie Robbins ice and mixer who
don't pick out individual amazed I know
people love to pick on an individual but
actually it's the whole system it's
stacked in a certain way and by the
system do you mean the civil service
it's also this the the advisory group
all all that all of these people and the
and that the simple truth is that
actually there is a resolution and by
the way you say said he's six months
actually that's plenty of time bluntly
I've always said the Prime Minister from
the beginning the issue in this is going
to be the last month it's not gonna be
the two years that run up to it so in
the last month because the European
Union always uses time always try to
pressurize you always takes you to what
they call the cliff edge and then sees
if you paint so you think there will be
a deal then yeah I think there would be
I think this 89 percent likely would be
a deal and I think actually the deal
will end up as something like what Boris
called super Canada what somebody else
called free-trade plus basically a free
trade rates do but we're going to have a
very scary few months between now and
about November it's gonna be really
scary
everybody's gonna be calling each
other's bluff it's all good all sorts of
brinksmanship gonna go on that's normal
that's better European Union you knows
daily bread you know and that's what
we've got to be ready for that's why
what making the argument now that's why
it was important to resign in
because we've got to make the arguments
in in the last round
checkers won't fly what's Ryan Europe
and it won't fly in Parliament so
process won't accept check I don't agree
with Boris Johnson madam well I think
you see what Brooke what Brussels may
well do it had some add a few more
things on but yeah a lot of people don't
like checkers even more I think it's the
absolute last step you can go they made
all the concessions again so Russell's
want to put something else nautical
customs union on the one of what you
know some other requirements money or
immigration or whatever and she hasn't
got any room for that I'm afraid so
I think checkers will die one way or
another either in Brussels or in
Westminster and then we'll need another
alternative and that's why I wrote a
basic I wrote that alternative last
lunch dear over a year ago well let's
talk about and the alternatives that are
on offer because there's a bit of an
inconvenient truth isn't there with your
alternate system of thought and that is
the Irish border situation it's very
serious and what happens with that
border that's awesome I don't accept the
phrase An Inconvenient Truth is an
inconvenient exaggeration and the reason
is I mean I'm unreasonably familiar with
the Irish broader over the course of 20
years or so the it there is already a
border there there's a customs board
over so there's a judicial board as a
currency border those borders all
operate invisibly you know you could any
way you can tell is the color of the
stripe in the middle of the road changes
covered over the border but the customs
operation by talking to each other the
Irish and and Northern Ireland customs
manage to catch lots of smugglers those
were the massive cigarette call Romeo
ago it can be done you talk about things
such as you know Currency Board of
example I mean it's a difference isn't
there between taking some euros over the
border and your pulpit and back again
and taking some sheep over the border
for example I mean it's a different kind
of border that we're talking about here
isn't it and it's not helpful really is
it to try and simplify the people over
simplifying it the Irish government and
the Commission by saying oh you're going
to have a sweeping political answer
there is no acceptable sweeping
political answer what do they have to do
is look at the detail the detail of tax
on the border because it's taxed the
biggest thing you're right it doesn't
matter where you carry a URL or pound
you can buy you can buy your drinks in
in Belfast the euros and you can buy
them in Dublin in pounds the the the
simple truth is it's a tax which we deal
with already it's regulations which is
the hardest one and it's what the core
rules of origin that is goods coming
from the rest of the world going into
Europe by bio codes back door through
Belfast we can control that only five
ports in a normal eye than five B port
we can control that the issue is
regulation and you're right it's it's
cattle been backs of [ __ ] across the
border it's milk going backwards and
pours across the border it's that sort
of thing and it's important isn't when
you and military man you know how
important how sensitive this is I mean
we're still I have long ago yeah yeah I
know some immutable but the
I raised this in negotiation before the
Commission bid for that exactly that
reason I think was a moral
responsibility there so it's not an
exaggeration if you know what I'm saying
is the problem is being exaggerated if
not the importance I don't don't and
must distinguish that and the regulatory
stuff well there are already special
arrangements of the law which apply it's
a single epidemiological zone so you
know when you take cattle into northern
either you don't have to inspect them so
you can protect that if there are
special regular fee arrangements the
other thing that's that's unify between
the North and South is what supposed to
sing the electricity market so you have
special arrangements on or denial of
electricity generators so you know
without putting that border in the area
you can do minor did not mine out but
the significant detail changes and
they're not even looking at this
original seed of the Irish government
before mr. Baraka came into power and
they were talking about these things and
all the sudden all stopped now it's
being used for political reasons it's a
very important issue but they're worth
being exaggerated is the difficulty of
resident result we can do it and look I
tell you that the best test rather
disappeared the details your your your
your viewers should just ask themselves
who do they believe in is David Trimble
on Northern Ireland the Nobel Prize
winner who put his life on the line to
create the Irish peace process or
Barnier or your Trimble is supports the
arguments I've put about resolving our
reporters so would you would you accept
along the transition to get this right
the border surface we don't need one I
mean we literally don't need
the you know we've got 21 months coming
anyway that's that's way beyond what we
need to do this most of these issues are
you know manageable not because not live
the delays the issue is not time the
issue is willingness to take on me take
on the problem and now another big
question of course and as we go into the
conference is leadership
Teresa Mays had a rocky few months
there's been in open discussions about
her future among conservative MPs would
you support her leading to conservatives
into the next election well that's up to
her frankly I mean from the beginning to
keep her in I mean look the the when I
resigned I took a great deal of trouble
to D personalize this because it seems
to me were conflating leadership on the
one hand and policy on the other I want
a change of policy not to change a
believer and where I differ from Baris
whose front pages of papers this morning
is he's conflating the two I think you
know this is such an important issue we
must keep it away from internal Tory
party battles and from leadership issues
such an important issue lots of things
he says I agree with but you know on
this we definitely let's talk about for
us Johnson shall we I mean do you think
he would make a good leader that'll
probably be after I've gone you take
what he said this morning and in the
papers there was a council hs2 and spend
it on a bridge nor darling well I would
I want to do that I wouldn't and I think
one of one of the blights of British
politics is politicians having fantastic
ideas that cost a fortune and don't do
much good and that will be one of if
you're gonna you're gonna use the money
use it for broadband or something else
on housing you know he's right the issue
is there but it's answers wrong you know
that we need to completely rewrite the
housing policy and so on so you know I
know
Boris is great made mine you know we we
were very knock about friendship
but you know quite a lot of his ideas I
think good headlines not their surgical
policy so not perhaps the right person
to I don't think it's an issue for today
I mean the real problem is if we
conflate this issue with the leave the
mode of brexit issue we can get motor
breaks it Rock because it gets conflated
with other things bricks it matters more
than any leadership issue or reach of
interest of any person that's the thing
the public should bear in mind Bret's it
mattered more than a person I wonder if
that applies to Jeremy Corbyn as well
and would you be prepared to vote down
the prime ministers we know that you
want to vote against it if it could mean
which it could mean a general election
and Jeremy Corbyn in number two um I
don't think is that something you'd want
to dismiss the premise really and I will
vote against checkers full stop and it
won't leave the general election I'm not
going to debate the fine tactics bill
that you're going to Majan that's quite
important how we do that but this is you
know we're capable of managing this
through
and the bigger what used to be the
threat was not poor but what used to be
the threat or was at the sort of World
Trade Organization or No Deal leave that
was the threat I know that inside out
I've been studying that for two and a
half years there are 300 plans to deal
with it I know it's not as frightening
as all the project fear things say so
I'll take that risk
but we weren't operating risk at all so
no no general election you don't know
general election but there will be a
very very exciting autumn in
emplacements what do you think happened
what because there because the
government said if it's not if it sticks
with check checkers it will loosen those
right and that could be a problem for
the prime minister losing votes is
always a problem for a government but
you know
governments have lost in the past I mean
I'm laid the first defeat of Tony Blair
on 90 days
he didn't suddenly design the next day
and that was a fundamental central
policy this cup